Donald Trump has lashed out on Truth
social at Ron DeSantis claiming that he
never thinks about the guy you all know
that with Trump if he tells you he's not
thinking about something then he almost
certainly is and we know Trump is
increasingly obsessed with Ron DeSantis
Ron DeSantis failed his loyalty pledge
to Trump because what Ron DeSantis
should have said when asked about might
you run in 2024 DeSantis should have
gotten down on his knees and prayed at
the altar of trump and said I will not
run if Donald Trump wants to be
president DeSantis hasn't done that and
in fact DeSantis is probably gearing up
to announce a presidential campaign he's
polling really well despite the fact
that he's not even running yet and Trump
is furious he's coming up with nicknames
and on and on the real question is
can DeSantis actually do well against
Trump in a national campaign with the
nicknames and the insults and the entire
thing